Let's say we have the simplest
of arithmetic sequences
and probably the simplest of sequences
one, two...
we're going to start at one
and just increment by one
one, two, three
and we're going to go all the way to n
And what I want to think about is
what is the sum of this sequence going to be?
And the sum of a sequence, we already know
we call a series
so what is the sum
and I will just call it Sn
what is this going to be equal to
one plus two plus three plus
going all the way to n
well, we're going to do a neat little trick here
where I'm going to rewrite this sum
so I will write it again as Sn
but now I'm just going to write it in reverse order
I'm going to write it as n plus n minus one
plus n minus two
all the way to one
and now I'm going to add these two equations
So we know that Sn is equal to this
so we are adding the same thing to both sides of this equation up here
So on the left hand side we're going to have Sn plus Sn
is just two times Sn
and on the right hand side
and this is where we start to see something kind of cool
you have a one plus an n
which is just going to be n plus one
you have a two plus n minus one
which is... well two plus n minus one
is going to be n plus one again
plus n plus one
you have a three plus n minus two
well that's going to be n plus one again
I think you see what is going on here
And we're going to go all the way to this last pair
I guess you could say, or call it these last two terms
and we have an n plus one again
plus n plus one
So how many of these n plus one's do we have?
well we have n of them
there were n of these terms in each of these equations
one two three... all the way to n
So, we can rewrite this thing as two times Sn
is equal to, and you have n (n+1) terms
so we could write it as n times n plus one
n times n plus one
and now to solve for Sn to solve for our sum
we can just divide both sides by two
And so we are going to be left with the sum from one to n
this arithmetic sequence where we're just incrementing by one
starting at one, is going to be equal to n times n plus one over two
And this is neat because now you can quickly find the sum
let's say from one to a hundred
it will be 100 times 101 over 2
So very quickly you can find these sums
And what I'm curious about and what we will explore in the next video
is can we generalize this for any arithmetic sequence
we started with a very simple one
we started at one, we just incremented by one
And it looks like
so if I were to write it this way
this is n times (n + 1) over 2
So this right over here, this n
this is the nth term in our sequence
and this right over here, this one
was the first term in our sequence
So at least in this case it looks like I took the average
of the first term and the nth term
so this right over here
this is the average
this right over here is the average
of a1 and an
and then I'm multiplying that times n
and what I'm curious about is whether this is going to be true
for any arithmetic sequence
that the sum of it is going to be the average of the first
and the last term times the number of terms